good evening we are hours away from the
next step in las vegas reopening and
tonight businesses are busy preparing
for new copic guidelines that will go
into effect
at midnight thanks for joining us at six
i'm denise feldas good evening i'm brian
loftis these changes are coming as
really great news for many small
business owners kate houston live
from pink desert boutique in centennial
hills with how they are preparing their
kate
yes well after months of vaccinations
and slowing the spread of covet 19 in
the community
restrictions are once again being
loosened now for small businesses like
pink desert
this is paving the way to hire more
employees and bring in
even more customers
we do have a smaller space and the
capacity limits have been hard as a
small business because
we have a great local customer support
base great news for local businesses
starting saturday capacity limits will
increase from 50 to 80 percent
and social distancing will go from six
feet to three feet
pink desert founder and designer darcy
shurig is busy preparing saying she'll
need to order new signs to reflect the
changes
i'm really excited as these restrictions
are continuing to loosen and we can get
more people in here
shurik says they'll now be able to
welcome in 12 people to the store just
in time for their mother's day sale
it will also pave the way to plan
in-store events
bringing speakers in and doing fun
parties learning classes
we've done cookie decorating and we're
just excited to get back to that part of
our brand
like pink desert performance footwear
has had to work through tight guidelines
in a smaller space
manager sarah wildfong says with spring
recreation well underway
this is a helpful boost with the
holidays and you know the influx of
people
getting out and doing things outside
because of the warm weather
it will be nice to have that option now
both businesses are looking to hire some
employees to meet the demand
wildfong is looking forward to planning
more running groups and events for
customers
we have shoe brands their reps they come
out they have people try on shoes
they kind of specialize that you know
get people out there get their name out
there
both businesses say that they're ready
to go back to full capacity
in order for that to happen 60 percent
of the eligible population in clark
county
will at need at least the first dose of
the covet 19 vaccine
reporting live tonight from pink desert
in centennial hills kate houston 8 news
now